Hey everyone, my name is Parth and I work on
agents at O Llama.
I'm Michael, one of the Co founders of O Llama.
And today we'll be talking about open models for agents
and how hybrid local cloud models are playing in together
to make agents a reality.
If you're having trouble listening to us or hearing us,
there's headsets at the back, so feel free to go
and grab one just as we get started.
Take it away.
Awesome, has anyone here heard about O Lama before?
Wow OK that's a quite a bit of people.
I'll still I'll go quick on the background, but what
is O Lama?
O Lama is really the easiest way for developers to
access open models and use it with your own tools.
O Lama is the easiest way in one command to
be able to run a model to just get started
by chatting with it.
Or recently we introduced this command O Lama Launch to
be able to integrate open models directly with your favorite
tools.
This could be clock code, VS Code, GitHub Copilot by
using O Lama Launch directly injecting the open models into
these harnesses.
And of course for developers building on top of these
open models, we have Open AI and Anthropic API compatibility
for you to build your own applications.
If you have Python or JavaScript applications, we also have
a great SDK for you to build up on top.
And O Lama since the beginning has been really built
for agents.
This means we specifically test O Lama for tool calling,
having structured outputs and have one line agent set up
for bringing all these models to O Llama platform.
And right now we have over 8 million active developers
using O Llama and we partner with major model labs
and hardware companies to continue to bring model launches and
hardware optimizations to O Llama.
So just this morning, Google DeepMind announced Jemma 412 B
unified model and it's already available on O Llama and
you can use it for your Agentech applications.
And recently starting this year, we added Olamas Cloud to
augment the local inference piece as well.
And this is a piece where your data is never
trained on it has zero data retention.
What it's meant to do is being able to run
Frontier models on data center grade hardware.
And this way, if you don't have the compute locally,
you're able to scale with Olama and continue to run
the models that you want.
And a lot of these use cases that are enabled
with O Llama are things like parallel agents to really
accomplish difficult work that you couldn't otherwise do with smaller
models.
And all these models come with the maximum contacts window
from the model providers themselves.
And this is, of course, completely optional service that you
can use with O Llama.
Now open models are quickly improving.
This is just one of the sweep bench verified for
illustration purposes.
But really the open models are enabling mainstream use cases
at significantly lower prices.
And we're seeing a lot of these mainstream use cases,
maybe not frontier research like DNA synthesis or frontier coding
applications.
Users with mainstream tasks are able to begin to use
these open models for.
And we'll show you demos of that and give real
life scenarios of where that's happening today and giving users
the flexibility to customize your models and run it with
the parameters that fit with your goals.
How open models have really improved capabilities and really evolved.
In the past, we've seen models really come with just
pure general chat.
And over the the months that followed, we really saw
models quickly evolving to having reason reasoning abilities to able
to start thinking.
And then models evolved to be able to pick up
individual tools and multiple tools.
And we're starting to see more open model labs become
beginning to release models that are capable of tackling long
horizon tasks.
So these are tasks that can run for hours and
and days.
And these are just starting to happen.
And so in the future, we should be beginning to
see much more of that unlock happening some of the
use cases that we've seen in real life and O
llamas really private.
So these are published papers that where a lot of
the users have talked about where they are publicly using
Olama, the Lawrence Berkeley National Laboratory.
They, they have an accelerator assistance system to autonomously execute
physics research for X-ray.
And they basically have a a routing layer that chooses
between cloud models and Olama in order to do their
inference.
And this is what their accelerator ultimately looks like.
And this is O Llama powering their X-ray research.
There's also the NASA Glenn Research Center.
They have a crew and health, crew health performance, probabilistic
risk assessment.
And they use O Llama to categorize a diverse set
of Mars mission tasks.
And they go into 18 predefined human system task categories
in order for their future missions.
the US Department of Energy with Brookhaven National Laboratory also
integrates Olama to facilitate log data analysis.
And this is one of their setup together with Lang
Chang that they use, allowing users to be able to
use a GUI to be able to do summaries of
their log information and retrieve specifics on the issues and
solutions through natural language.
And there are other developers in enterprises already using a
llama to automate their mission critical tasks.
For example, a multinational media company processes financial documents for
their quarterly earnings review and SEC filings and these are
very sensitive data to that they use and it just
cannot be sent to other cloud AI models or providers.
And this is where their use case for O Lama
lies.
A leading industry manufacturer has an assistant internally using O
Lama to design machine parts and this is all for
their Mechanical Engineers to do CAD Design Motive Automotive manufacturer
is using O Lama directly on the factory floor and
this is leveraging retrieval, augmented generation on their knowledge base
and inspection system for their factory technicians.
And we'd love to pass it to Parth for quick
demos on what a llama looks like.
Cool.
So I'll cover a bunch of different things that we
can do and hopefully you'll walk away with a better
sense of everything a llama can do for you now,
especially both local and cloud.
So one of the things that a lot of you
probably know us for is, you know, the classic bread
and butter chatting with a model.
So you can see here, a big focus that we
have is to focus on both local and cloud and
have the experience feel the exact same.
So you want to do a larger task, you want
to use a bigger model, you use cloud almost the
same way you would use a local model.
So as Michael mentioned, we introduced O Lama launch earlier
this year and essentially it's a way to connect to
all your favorite tools and applications for whatever you'd like
to do.
So we support personal agents like Open Claw, Hermes, as
well as a plethora of agentic harnesses to do coding
agents and coding work.
So here's a list, you know, we have plot code,
codecs, Copilot, CLI, Droid Pie, and many, many more and
many more are also coming.
So I'll show you a little bit about how it's
super easy to plug Olama into any of these favorite
tools that you may have, and I'll showcase Copilot in
this case.
So as I mentioned earlier, you just type Olama launch
Copilot and you can pick the model that you'd like.
So in this case, I'm using Kimi K 2.6 on
our cloud, but just as easily you can use a
local model as well.
And one of the things I really like about the
Copilot CLI is that you can directly pick which issues
you want to work on.
And so in this case, I'm like, OK, go and
fetch this issue.
Let's see you know what it's doing and let's come
up with a solution for it.
So thinking likes to think a lot sometimes and you
know, it's come up with exactly what's going on in
the issue.
And I can use this as part of my workflow
to directly without ever leaving my terminal and leveraging these
open models to do real work.
And this is a workflow that I often do in
my day-to-day.
So, you know, I ask, are there any open PRS
referencing?
It says no.
And then, you know, we start working on a fix.
And so any other agent harnesses that you've, you know,
used a lot of powers them similarly as well where
we make sure that the underlying technologies work, things like
sub agents, web search, etcetera.
So over here it's spun up multiple sub agents to
go and explore the code base and come up with
potential fixes.
Just skipping forward a little bit basically gives me a
little bit of a plan and then I can execute
on this plan and get my work done.
Another thing I feel is so critical is this idea
of hybrid execution.
So cloud models, especially the ones that we serve, which
are very, very close to frontier level intelligence, they are
awesome for your most difficult work when it comes to
coding or any other agentic tasks.
But there's a lot of stuff you want to be
extremely, extremely private for.
And this is a workflow that I often use in
my day-to-day or quarterly, as you'll see, which is my
credit card statement.
And so this is not my actual credit card statement.
That would be a little bit weird, but it is
a fake 1.
And so this is some, this is a pretty usual
workflow I'll do at the end of every month.
I'll basically go take my credit card statement and put
it into one of my favorite harnesses called π so
Π's a really minimal harness if you haven't heard about
it.
And it's perfect for local models as the entire point
is that it doesn't float the system prompt.
It keeps everything super minimal.
So in this case, I'm using Quant 3.6 running locally
on my MacBook.
And I'm basically going to say, you know, process this
statement and show me kind of how much I'm spending
whatever the different categories.
And so let's see it in action.
So this is running fully locally on my computer for
my most private and private use cases.
And in this case, it's able to write code to
process the PDF.
And now it's able to give me a little bit
of a spending breakdown because it's not processed that information.
Let's see, it's doing a bit of math to figure
out exactly what's going on and then there we go.
So none of this information ever left my computer.
It's been here.
Seems like I'm spending a lot on travel.
I guess I'm overdue for another vacation.
But I think it's really, really useful to be able
to have this level of like good enough.
And a big thing we've seen over the last few
months is that you truly have this idea where local
models are actually viable to do real work.
And another really cool thing that I personally really like
using is using local models for personal harnesses.
So personal agents like Hermes and open Claw because none
of your information ever leaves and you can kind of
start feeding it information.
Everything's living on your computer anyways.
And so I'd love to show you open claw.
One of the cool things that we can do with
open Claw is install it for you.
And so this is like a complete end to end
setup.
I wrote, oh, Llama launch open claw ran it.
It's installing open Claw lets me choose a model and
gets me set up right with it.
And so within like 30 seconds, I'm able to go
from absolutely nothing installed to and running open client since
ready to do my work for me.
Cool And with that, we'd like to open up the
floor for any questions that you may have around local
cloud O llama.
So welcome to come up to the mic and then
we'll also hang around after as well.
Hello stops working.
I was wondering since the focus is on this part
of the focus was on running on device.
Sorry.
Would you be able to speak louder?
Sure, I'll try.
So I was wondering some part, since part of the
focus is on running on the device itself, what are
your thoughts on at the edge devices like mobile phones
or smaller systems that may not have the same power
as a laptop?
Sorry, just to repeat the question, did you mean what
type of models are good for different systems?
Not necessarily what type of models, but specifically if there
are plans to have all LAMA integrations directly at the
edge for again maybe iPhones or Android devices that may
not have the same power as your regular Mac.
Yeah, we haven't targeted mobile devices yet.
There are people who have experimenting, been experimenting, bringing Olama
on mobile devices and it it does run.
So Olama's absolutely enabled on Qualcomm Snapdragon devices and it's
the same chipset that runs on mobile.
And we have seen users do that.
We're not directly targeting mobile devices yet because we want
to target the mainstream use cases for work.
Thank you.
Any other questions, feel free to hop onto the mic
or raise your hand and we'll guide you over.
Do you want to drop to the mic?
Yeah.
Can you talk a little bit about VRAM and unified
RAM and sort of model sizes context windows?
I saw that at least in the demo, you had
a 262K context window.
What kind of a machine do you have?
And you know, what are the specs?
Yeah.
Is it a quantized model?
For sure.
So obviously like in a llama, we have a default
quantization that we recommend for most things.
And now we also have support for MLX where we
actually run NVFP 4.
And with all that, I have a Max out Max
so I can run a full context length, especially with
a smaller model and get, you know, most of my
work done and not really have to worry about compaction
as much.
Because what tends to happen as soon as you're running
agentic workloads locally is you start running into being hardware
constraint where you can't support the maximum context length.
So unified memory is great in the sense that it
lets you have larger context lengths with a slight trade
off of that speed that you would get on, you
know, a CUDA card, for example.
But at the same time, you get to work a
lot more with a larger memory, so you get to
support harder and harder tasks.
And I'm sure that as you know, time goes on,
even unified memory will get better in terms of performance
and speed.
On the hardware front, we've been seeing most of the
hardware partners are getting into unified memory started with Apple,
NVIDIA and Microsoft just announced RTX Spark that has unified
memory up to 128 gigabytes.
Of course, AMD has the strict, say, Halo platform that
also can go up to 128 gigabytes I believe.
And and so we're seeing across the board different hardware
teams moving towards unified memory.
Hey, building on Apple Silicon devices, building on device platform
for models that are running on iPhone and Mac OS
and Fission Pro also watch OS.
Tried alarm a couple weeks back.
Are you still using Llama CPP under the hood?
Any plan to build your own inference engine by the
way?
So we do have our own MLX inference engine.
So if you are on an Apple device, highly recommend
using that one just because you got like faster performance.
And for that you just need to pull one of
the MLX models from our model registry.
Thank you.
Any other questions?
Yeah, yeah, sure.
So the question was what's the best coding model on
128 GB MacBook?
Honestly, one of my favorites is 1362070 if I'm remembering
correctly, as well as Gemma.
I kind of use them in pairs to go and
write like smaller scripts for me for the most part.
Honestly like a little bit underrated, but even the GB2SS120B
works really well for doing scripting and other tasks.
Awesome, I.
Was going to add the Gemma 4 dense models are
actually really performant.
And you'd be able to run them on a full
context length as well.
Yeah.
So, so the question is like how do you choose
which model to use?
It really depends on kind of your task for coding.
You know, different models will perform better versus like personal
agents sometimes or you know, even if you're just using
for like a chat use case or classification for whatever
reason.
And a big way that I recommend people to go
about choosing a model is honestly like trying a bunch
out.
We're going to start doing better recommendations in terms of,
you know, if you're using a certain harness of as
part of a llama launch, you'd be able to see
kind of which are the up and date models which
you can use best for your system as well.
But for the most part, if you're building like a
bespoke app, then the best thing you can do is
try a bunch out, benchmark it and see which one
you prefer the most.
And I think with that, well.
Conclude the session.
We're going to hang around for a while.
Come chat with us.
We have a bunch of stickers to give away.
Thank you.